Let's go next to our caller from the 5 1 6
area code who's been holding on for a while,
5 1 6.
What's your name?
Where you calling from?
Hey, what's going on, David?
Hey, Anthony, what's up, Anthony?
You know what?
Not much of a going back and forth with my
friend in regards to a theory that I had,
because, you know, I don't want to get on
the show for a while.
And at this point, and when it comes to Trump
there, there's really no good answer for it.
Regardless, if you try to get him out or just
his supporters, there doesn't seem to be any
good answer.
So while I can, I'll ask you this question.
My body always has a problem with letters.
He says they're moving too fast.
And my question to him is, you know what?
I agree.
It's you know, I don't really follow politics
too much.
But do you think the left is moving so quickly
because the right has held them back for so
long?
Like things on just, you know, basic like
gay marriage and global like global warming.
They've held them back for so long.
So now they have a footing.
They're trying to go to things.
What has the left done that's been super fast?
Like what's an example?
Well, that's that's his argument.
And I'm just trying to get like no matter
what I throw at him, like I always try to
bring up Trump and like his press briefings.
Right.
And I tell I God, you show me an example.
But one thing they've done very well is just
what about this person?
You never seem to answer the question that's
being asked about one particular person.
You know, heavens.
If your friend says the left is moving too
fast, I don't know that I'd talk about Trump's
press briefings, I'd say.
What what is the left move too fast, Don?
Because I haven't.
I mean, listen.
Obamacare.
It took the idea of Obamacare was first proposed
in like the early 90s by the Heritage Foundation.
And it was passed in 2010.
So in 17 years, we got health care dot gov
and a rule about preexisting conditions and
26 year olds.
That's that's too fast.
Gay marriage, the first state to legalize
gay marriage was Massachusetts in I think
was 2003.
In 2015, the Supreme Court, that's 12 years.
I would just say, where has the left?
Where is the left moving so fast?
I don't see anywhere that the left is moving
fast.
Huh?
You know what, like that because I more or
less, whenever I try to bring something up,
I'll say something like, oh, they're doing
this, the Green New Deal.
And I and I knock.
I don't know the details of it.
I just know that it's a guideline.
Look, it's an idea.
What's the problem with just having an idea
like, oh, they're just doing that.
I see.
So really what your friend is saying, he's
so here.
Here's what your friend is actually saying.
Your friend is not pointing to things that
have been done.
Your friend is saying Democrats are thinking
too big.
Democrats ideas, are you forward looking?
But I would point out if I were you.
None of that stuff has been done.
None of it has been done.
If you actually look at listened, Republicans
want to ban all or almost all abortions that's
whacked.
Now they've done smaller things at the state
level.
But if I say Republicans are moving too fast
by trying to ban all abortion, I'm wrong because
they haven't actually moved there.
They've been equally radical for a long time.
So tell your friend there's a difference between
an idea and actually doing stuff and that,
in fact, it's Republicans that have been preventing
any progress.
You know what, David, I appreciate you taking
my call.
I know you got other callers, a great job
doing everything you do.
Thank you so much.
All right.
Anthony, great to hear from you